[Music]
hi uncle Scheer I'm a suffragette near
here at Google Cloud and hi for me
Kelly I'm a program manager on the
training team on this episode we'll look
at cloud sequel a managed service that
helps make the management of my sequel
in Postgres databases far less painful
we'll be taking you through a quick demo
of a self-paced lab where we'll create
and connect to a cloud sequel my single
instance and perform some basic sequel
operations so stick around for that if
you're using a Postgres database engine
no problem we'll point you to that lab
as well
cloud sequel is a fully managed database
service that lets your hand off to
Google the often time-consuming yet
necessary tasks think of applying
patches and updates or managing backups
and configuring replications this allows
you to focus on building great apps
whether you're using my sequel or
Postgres cloud sequel allows you to set
up and configure an instance in just a
few steps for better performance you can
keep your data close to the services
that need it by selecting the most
suitable geographical region to run your
resources
the Samsung lab shows you how to create
and connect to a plot equal my sequel
instance and perform basic sequel
operations using the GCP console and the
my sequel client and we haven't
forgotten about you if you use Postgres
we have a lab just for you either one
will take about 30 minutes to complete
and you can check out the links to start
the quick labs here at this point in the
lab we've enabled the cloud sequel API
created a cloud sequel instance
and connected to the instance using the
my sequel client in cloud shell now we
are going to create a sequel database on
the cloud sequel instance we are going
to insert sample data into the guestbook
database we created we're going to
retrieve the data and see the two guests
we added we hope you enjoyed this
episode you're welcome to share your
experiences or ideas of using cloud
sequel in the comment section below if
you haven't already done so check out
the link where you can apply what you've
learned using a three hundred dollar
free trial credit on Google cloud
platform all of our additional training
resources are linked below thanks again
for watching and see you soon
you